[Música]
se cumple en 11 años desde la entrada en
vigor en Estados Unidos del programa
daca que protege a unos 800.000
migrantes que han entrado irregularmente
al país siendo niños el presidente
impidió al congreso que encuentra una
solución legal definitiva para los
soñadores ampliamos desde Washington
en Colombia falta un último debate que
determinará si se legaliza el mercado
del Cannabis en el país Este paso
definitivo es la votación del pleno del
senado que se prevé se realice la
próxima semana se requieren 54 votos
para dar luz verde al proyecto
la presidenta del Perú Dina boluarte le
cerró la puerta al adelanto de
elecciones e informó que culminará el
actual periodo de gobierno que termina
en julio 2026 Es la primera vez que la
mandataria niega rotundamente la
celebración de comicios anticipados Pues
en otras ocasiones había dejado la
responsabilidad en manos del congreso
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos porque se cumplieron 11
años desde la entrada en vigencia del
programa de acción diferida para los
llegados en la infancia conocido como
daca el presidente impidió el congreso
que elabore una solución legal
definitiva para los 800,000 migrantes
que están bajo protección y que son
conocidos Como soñadores desde la
capital estadounidense Cristóbal Vázquez
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplió la
información
en el aniversario décimo primero del
programa de acción diferida daca el
presidente insistió en los llamados al
congreso para lograr otorgarle un camino
a la legalidad a los jóvenes soñadores
que hacen parte del programa daca un
programa Que Barack Obama otorgó en su
momento para la protección contra la
deportación a aquellos que llegaron como
menores de edad a Estados Unidos el
programa que hoy tiene más de 800.000
jóvenes soñadores a los que concedió
esta protección y la capacidad de
trabajar en Estados Unidos ha estado
congelado desde el 2021 por problemas
legales ese año un tribunal de
apelaciones confirmó una decisión que
bloqueaba nuevas inscripciones de
jóvenes en el programa además Trump
intentó poner fin a daca en su momento
pero fue bloqueado por la Corte Suprema
once años después soñadores activistas
siguen presionando para la aprobación de
la ley Dream que se ha presentado Ya
varias veces al congreso y que le
otorgaría un camino hacia la ciudadanía
para los jóvenes soñadores sin embargo
es casi seguro que en una cámara de
representante es de mayoría republicana
este impulso fracase el presidente de
México mantuvo una reunión con la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
bonder Legend este jueves Andrés Manuel
López Obrador reveló a través de su
cuenta de Twitter que acordaron
apresurar la firma del tratado de libre
comercio entre México y la Unión Europea
previamente Wonder layín había asegurado
que el encuentro serviría para
fortalecer los lazos económicos entre el
bloque y el país norteamericano
vamos a la capital de Cuba donde tuvo
lugar la reunión entre el presidente
Miguel Díaz canel y su homólogo iraní
Ibrahim Racing los líderes firmaron seis
acuerdos de cooperación en política
exterior telecomunicaciones y minería
entre otros como es la última parada de
la gira del líder iraní que también
incluyó Venezuela y Nicaragua y calificó
de estratégicas las relaciones de su
país con estas tres naciones para
oponerse a lo que llamó el sistema
hegemónico y unilateral de Estados
Unidos
Colombia está un paso de legalizar la
venta y producción de marihuana Más allá
de la que tiene uso medicinal Solo falta
un debate en el senado y si se aprueba
el proyecto de ley se convertiría en el
tercer país latino en permitirla luego
de Uruguay y México pero el camino para
llegar hasta este punto ha sido largo y
comenzó hace décadas el camino para la
legalización de la marihuana en Colombia
ha sido largo y complejo en 1986 la ley
30 que adopta el estatuto Nacional de
estupefacientes Reguló el uso de la
marihuana
estableció la dosis para consumo
personal de Cannabis en máximo 20 gramos
la legislación además permitía el
cultivo de 20 plantas
en 1994 el gobierno despenalizó la
posesión y el uso personal de la
marihuana pero no su comercialización
el país sudamericano también abrió paso
al uso terapéutico de la planta en 2016
la marihuana medicinal fue legalizada su
uso puede ser autorizado por una receta
médica el entonces ministro de salud de
Colombia Alejandro Gaviria defendía así
el paso que daría la nación da un cambio
cultural que se está dando en todas
partes que obliga a actualizar nuestras
leyes y que obliga a cambiar la forma
como se ha regulado el consumo en
particular el consumo de marihuana
medicinal entonces de alguna manera
Colombia se está poniendo a Tono con el
mundo desde entonces los intentos de
legalizar su venta y producción se han
multiplicado sus Defensores aseguran que
sería un cambio de paradigma en el país
por un lado argumentan que se trata de
una manera de propiciar un consumo
responsable además de reducir el acceso
a sustancias consideradas más peligrosas
como la cocaína y la heroína
y por el otro señalan que ayudaría a
combatir el narcotráfico en uno de los
principales países productores de
marihuana en el mundo
la política prohibición instalada
encarecido un producto que sin control
Estatal ha enriquecido y potenciado a
organizaciones criminales que siguen en
expansión en el mundo sus ganancias
estimadas por última vez en 2009 eran de
84 mil millones de dólares anuales la
regularización sin embargo ha tenido
grandes detractores que alegan que su
consumo acarrea problemas de salud y que
legalizarla promocionaría su consumo
vamos a Perú porque en una declaración
tajante la presidenta Dina boluarte dijo
que la puerta celebrar elecciones
anticipadas está cerrada Es la primera
vez que la mandataria firma algo así
pues en ocasiones anteriores había
pasado esta responsabilidad del Congreso
que se negó adelantar comicios en cinco
ocasiones así las cosas su periodo irá
hasta Julio de 2026 Francisco Zacarías
corresponsal en Lima nos amplia los
detalles
la presidenta Dina boluarte afirmó que
el adelanto de elecciones en Perú está
cerrado y que ella y los integrantes de
su gobierno continuarán trabajando en
forma responsable en respeto al Estado
de derecho la democracia y la
Constitución hasta Julio de 2026 la
mandataria peruana realiza esta
pronunciamiento en momentos en que tiene
un 77% de desaprobación a sujeción según
últimas encuestas sus opositores le
recuerdan que la negativa de al adelanto
de elecciones por parte del parlamento y
su gobierno fue la exigencia al
estallido social en el sur del Perú que
se extendió a diferentes regiones del
país precisamente diversos colectivos
sociales están convocando a nueva
jornadas de protesta para el 19 de julio
en rechazo a Dina boluarte por las
muertes ocurridas en las marchas que se
desarrollaron entre diciembre de 2022 y
enero de 2023 algunos analistas
advierten que boluarte no conecta con la
población que está generando mayor
rechazo por otro lado señalan que la
jefa de estado se encuentra a punto de
perder el apoyo de la derecha en el
congreso quienes podría censurar a sus
ministros y quizás luego emprender un
proceso impeachment o vacancia
presidencial contra la gobernante en las
últimas horas la lideresa opositora
keiko fujimori criticó la situación de
Dina boluarte y anunció un cambio de
actitud de su bancada en el congreso y
Perú justamente vive un nuevo brote de
dengue el más grave en seis años que ha
causado la muerte de al menos 200
personas piura provincia del Norte del
país se convirtió en el epicentro allí
los hospitales no dan abasto para
atender a los pacientes y las
situaciones preocupantes especialmente
para los niños cuyos casos se agravan
más el informe es de Samuel Salgado
esta familia llora frente al cuerpo sin
vida de enfermaría ancajima una niña de
11 años que murió por dengue es el
rostro de una de las más de 200 personas
muertas en lo corrido del año por esta
enfermedad viral en Perú
se hizo
todo lo que se alcance de nosotros pero
lastimosamente no se pudo la ayuda de la
población
ha decidido infinitamente de la
población la lengua la lengua está
ubicada en el distrito de catacaos en la
provincia de piura esta zona del Norte
del país es una de las que registra más
casos de dengue según el Centro Nacional
de epidemiología prevención y control de
enfermedades piura es una de las
provincias donde más circula el aedes a
egipte
mosquito vector de dengue zika y
Chikungunya las Fuertes lluvias y el
calor producido por el fenómeno del niño
han convertido a piura en el centro del
actual brote de dengue el peor desde
el agua estancada utilizada a veces por
la falta de agua potable atrae a los
mosquitos teolinda Silva es madre de
Gabriel quien presenta síntomas de
dengue pero no ha podido acceder a
atención médica su organismo está no que
lo que está pasando por dentro porque
lamentablemente no tengo dinero para
poderlo llevar a una clínica y ver qué
es lo que le pongan no que lo que lo
examinen que lo que tenga los más
afectados por el brote han sido los
niños y los adultos mayores en piura el
30% de personas infectadas son niños y
ellos rápidamente pueden ser pasibles de
poder fallecer Entonces necesitan
pediatras porque la atención no es lo
mismo de un médico general la falta de
suministros y personal médico en los
hospitales de piura está grabando la
emergencia sanitaria fin de la
informativo gracias por su sintonía
[Música]